how do I start how do I get into this
social media games how do I put out my
stuff very simply step one the manifesto
first you got to figure out what or why
you want to talk about it for me Legacy
of being an entrepreneur or giving
advice and then number two you've got to
figure out where you're going to deploy
your first piece of Manifesto content
you're this rant this mission statement
there's only really Three core ways in
the current Internet to really
communicate to the world the written
word or video what I'm doing right now
am I talking it's screwing you up I love
it
um audio and then finally distribution
if it's written word you look at the
mediums the LinkedIn the wordpresses you
start a blog if it's video you've got
YouTube Facebook you've got Instagram if
it's audio you've got SoundCloud
Sketcher Google Voice iTunes you've got
to get distribution the way you do that
is either through time or money money is
easy Facebook ads Google ads time is
hard but if you have no money it's your
only option if you want people to know
about your stuff you need to find other
places that have eyeballs or ears and
get it out there that's how you start